thousands of anti-government protesters
are back on the streets of Lebanon's
capital maintaining their demand for the
entire political system to be reformed
organizers are calling the latest
rallies the sunday of unity
they say political dynasties that have
shared power for decades have only
enriched themselves and mismanaged
Lebanon's economy the Prime Minister
Santha didi quit on Tuesday but
protesters say that isn't enough let's
go now to our correspondent saying in a
hollow she's joining us live from the
capital Beirut so what's happening there
Xena
well the mood is one of defiance people
here are just uncompromising they
continue to insist that it is not enough
that the Prime Minister has resigned
they're calling for a new government a
technocratic government that will
prepare for early elections an overhaul
of the political system they want the
political elite those in power to resign
easier said than done and people here
even admit that and acknowledge that
because those in power have been in
power for 30 years now they remain
powerful and they still have support in
the streets while this protest movement
can rally tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands so can the other side and that
is what they have been doing showing
that they too have support now people
here understand that if their movement
is just confined to public squares
across the country it will do little to
maintain the pressure on the government
a few days ago security forces moved in
preventing them from blocking roads now
what we are hearing is that they're
planning to resort to road closures
tomorrow they're also calling for a
general strike
so escalatory measures to maintain the
pressure on those in power they turned
out in large numbers to send a message
to those trying to topple the ruling
elite supporters of President Michelle
Allen came from across the country and
converged outside the presidential
palace
Beirut suburbs a show of force but also
a call for cooperation there are too
many protest squares the situation must
not turn arenas against each other or
protest against each other
we drew a road map with three points
corruption the economy and a civic
nation there your rights so that's why
we need to communicate with you and
agree and put efforts together people
here say they too are asking for reforms
and an end to corruption but unlike the
anti-establishment protest movement they
are defending their leaders the
president's son-in-law foreign minister
Gibran Basile gave no indication he is
leaving office he is a divisive figure
who has been accused of corruption
overstepping his powers and exploiting
Lebanon sectarian structure for
political games
let us not block the road in front of us
with demands that are impossible to
achieve today because you'll speed up
the financial collapse the priorities to
delay that collapse and maybe prevent it
mainly sectarian parties still command
support among Lebanon's 4 million people
but the street is divided in public
squares in cities across the country
anti-government protesters are
uncompromising Lebanese from all sects
have been coming together and the crowds
chant the same slogan all of them means
all of them they are rejecting the
entire political class Lebanon so-called
October Revolution is now in its third
week the revolt against politicians who
have been in power for 30 years has not
lost momentum public pressure has
reshuffled power the Prime Minister
saddle hadiri risen last week but he
could return to office as part of a deal
politicians seem to be putting together
and what they seem to be discussing are
shares and divisions in the old practice
and perhaps maybe just maybe like
thinking about do we give the so-called
civil society two or three still see
to come down the street the problem is
what you hear here when you talk to
people is we want a coherent independent
competent government the major reform
these people want is proving difficult
to achieve and no one knows how long the
political standoff will last the
Lebanese army security forces were
getting reports that they're deploying
in a number of areas across the country
they want to prevent protesters from
blocking the roads yet again they did
that for two weeks the country was
paralyzed the country was crippled but
definitely there is a deep political
crisis in this country a dangerous one
and people are worried the where the
country is heading especially because
the economy the state of the economy is
dire zina thank you for that for now
that is a Nahar over the latest live in
Beirut thank you